hello and welcome everyone this is
active inference live stream guest
stream number 54.1
it's August 25th
2023. today we're going to be hearing
about electromagnetic field topology as
a solution to the boundary problem of
Consciousness this is going to be a
co-presentation followed by a discussion
with our guests here so I will leave it
to everyone to introduce themselves and
present and discuss however they prefer
and thank you again for joining please
thank you so much uh for having us
Daniel uh yeah I mean there is a
co-founder of quality Research Institute
and uh yeah uh I'm here with a Chris and
eliebert Chris clother release paper and
and the Lieber volunteer and uh Wiki
extraordinaire for a qri but yeah go
ahead uh Chris and Hillary yes
no no no no no more to say that that's
plenty let's let's get into the detail
yeah I'm good working with qri and a lot
into active in France so I'm and I'm
trying to unify with active influence a
lot and yeah
beautiful uh yeah I mean essentially
yeah next next slide essentially our
um
outline of this presentation is gonna
essentially walk you through some of the
key ideas of the paper
um and kind of like trying to illustrate
them or making them a little bit more
intuitive
um fairly high level although we will
actually present kind of the the core
the core argument
um the main thing to to to point out
here uh next slide is that
the genetic theories of Consciousness
you know I guess like 20 years ago they
sounded like a total total crackpot type
yeah I've still got a good connection so
we can give him a moment or two yeah if
not I'll I'll pick up from
what was the crackpot
vehicle next oh my gosh
um sorry please repeat from crackpot
oh yeah oh my God yeah uh over the last
20 years however there's been an
explosion of interest in electromagnetic
theories of Consciousness and serious
peer-reviewed Publications about them
especially the last 10 and then five
years kind of like a variable
exponential explosion in terms of a
number of like serious articles
published and one of the very very kind
of like key amazing kind of like
contributions that something like
Connecticut magnetic Theory Of
Consciousness can offer to the overall
ecosystem of philosophy of mind is that
it provides a way to solve
question for how information can be
combined I mean essentially when you
have information specifically
distributed how is it possible that they
can be simultaneously part of some kind
of like unified whole
and electromagnetic theories of
Consciousness are just very proud to say
well the electromagnetic field is
ontologically unitary it's already
unified so there's not much of a problem
here
um if however you know once you kind of
like have this this uh Unity uh then the
question becomes well but how do you
actually draw a boundary around it so
actually you just traded one problem for
another so
it's the guy yeah dig into the details
there
oh should I take us through the
literature reviewers context for this
and then Andrews will come back to kind
of give you the the solution that we
think can fit with electromagnetic
fields
so yeah the boundary problem let's so
binding problem you heard just now into
a first approximation that is
whatever you think might make up
Consciousness maybe it's neurons firing
maybe it's some sort of magical choir at
the bottom of the universe whatever you
think it is these small things need to
be bound together to ex to reflect the
complex phenomenology we have we see
lots of things all at once right now I'm
I'm smelling the flowers outside I've
got the laptop screen in front of me
there's lots of stuff happening all at
once in a unified way so that's the
binding problem we won't do more on that
here we'll sort of assume some
familiarity with it but then the
boundary problem is well once you've got
a mechanism that creates The Binding
between these lower level entities
why would that mechanism ever stop
because clearly our awareness our
phenomenology doesn't go on forever we
don't know what's happening in Alpha
Century our awareness is not unbounded
and as soon as you realize that you need
boundaries around something
a number of things suddenly don't quite
make sense so Owen Schrodinger or
physics Fame flagged this up as one of
the things that he felt was completely
unresolved so despite his his kind of
vast intellect and his contributions
elsewhere he felt that this puzzle was
one of the things that he described as
when he turns his mind to it everything
just evaporates none of it none of it
makes sense anymore he can't get a grip
on the problem and he described the
problem
as you can see on the screen he was
saying why is it that my identity is at
the intermediate level this kind of
roughly human-shaped body
and you can say okay well mostly mean
the central nervous system but either
way this this broad entity has lots of
smaller things inside it cells organs
human bodies and lots of things above it
cities states solar systems universes
and so on
why is our self-consciousness always at
this always at this one level and if you
describe that as a problem to somebody
who's never heard of it before or never
thought of it before
they may if this happens to me just just
last Friday they might say
well it's obviously just like
the body stops like the skull stops here
or like my arm stops here like of of
course it's not going out to our first
century why why would it and that's it's
a very intuitive immediate human
reaction but you probe it a little bit
as Schrodinger did and it kind of falls
apart
because
if you're a you're on firing somewhere
in the central nervous system and you're
being
initiated by a neuron in the peripheral
nervous system well how do you know to
stop binding how do you know that
there's a boundary that stops at the
edge of the central nervous system or if
your if your fingers are holding onto a
tool and you're getting feedback from
that tool you're driving a car it can
feel like you're part of that car how
does where does the system know where
the boundary is because most of these
things that we observe have
only Observer dependent
boundaries if you've got a wheel in a
car rolling along the road from one
perspective it looks like the wheel is
separate from the road but if you're a
tiny ant or something and the car is
parked these things all may feel like
they're one object
and this was when when Schrodinger
turned his mind to this it puzzled him
so there's that's given the benefit of
the doubt that's let's say that there's
something real to be puzzled through
here
this issue applies both to the example I
started with around building up in small
units but also if you're a cosmo pan
psychist you believe that there is one
universal Consciousness and we are like
a god playing with its puppets
in that case you still have the same
question because you're still
demarcating boundaries you just get the
mirror image we'll mostly focus on the
idea of expanding up from small things
because that's closer to the Orthodoxy
but there's no you can't solve this
problem magically by by declaring a
single consciousness
okay so that's that's what that
and say much more about this he just
said that this was a this was a puzzle
the first person we found that really
formalized this and gave it the name
boundary problem
was Rosenberg and it was a number of
pieces late 90s early 2000s
and he uses the phrase sitter and
cryptus but it's exactly the same idea
as schroeding I had one of them is well
why aren't there lots of small things I
think that's I think that might have
been the Silla that might have been the
the the nine-headed monster and then on
the other hand what about the things
that we are nested within and we call
that the Caribbean and he said it's very
hard to posit
a genuinely robust mechanism that would
stop it in both directions
you can imagine a reason why lots of
small things get bound together but why
would the binding stop and yeah his view
in framing this problem is that no one
had solved it
winding on to Anders and I chatting
about this last year and building on
some of qri's foundational work in this
area we wanted to know well what's
happened since Rosenberg framed this and
schroding was so puzzled by it like
surely someone's come up with a few
solutions to it
so Q standards database driven
literature review and you've got the
details there that fairly standard stuff
what we what we looked looking across
the scopus database we only found five
papers that seem to be relevant about
the boundary problem compared to 92 on
The Binding
and 47 on the combination problem so
some of these related problems and in
our intro we kind of went straight from
binding to boundary they are so you know
if you're thinking about one you really
should be thinking about the other
well that is not reflected in the
literature
we did a bit more puzzling around
people don't seem to be referring to
this by other names or when they are
they haven't solved it either
um so
it felt that there was something worth
going out here and this is what what
initiated the paper
what we did find though in partly in
those five papers and partly in looking
around we do find families of possible
solutions
and there's no clear winner but maybe
philosophy rarely has a clear winner for
anything so maybe that's an unreasonable
expectation but there's definitely open
questions for each class of theories
that have been put out there to solve
this problem
so the first of these Loosely termed
algorithmic so computational causal
structure theories I'm just trying to
summarize them in into one term some of
the examples there IIT of course very
well known uh Global workspace Theory as
well
they will tend to say that things bind
together when they're in a particular
pattern so you might imagine a database
that references itself or the working
memory of a computer or as soon as
things are somehow linked together in a
causal sense in IIT there's a particular
type of pattern but nonetheless it's an
abstract informational relationship
those papers don't tend to be super
explicit about defining boundaries
normally they let's say IIT will
normally say here's our system
and now let's ask within that system
where is the highest Buy
they sort of just say take the
boundaries on that says no one has said
this take the whole universe as a system
that the math is already virtually
impossible at even even toy systems
but reading between the lines or reading
some of the other papers around it
there's something about
if you had a high quite area surrounded
by lots of low-fi areas well it's
natural that it's the it's the bit
that's high and there's this principle
of exclusion that says you take the
highest one in a system
maybe you have to specify a system
before it makes sense to ask that
and if you took the highest bit out
somehow you just remove some of those
causal interconnections that create that
that highness
whatever's left will have a slightly
lower bit of Phi and that is now where
the the the sort of locus of
Consciousness resides
this may well work kind of the maths
would need working out I think Andrews
and I are initially skeptical
um but because as best as we can see no
one's really created complicated maps
and discussed what would happen when
you've got different mixtures of
densities that are shifting over time
what stops it from being arbitrary
certainly there are there are questions
to be had and we should come back to
this a bit if we want to talk about it
further but suffice it to say
it's not a guaranteed solution and
there's one critique that we we cite
there
resonance theories
um
a link between those and electromagnetic
fields now as well in the the main
progenitor of these theories Tom Hunt
would say that the the main resonance
which he sees binding happening together
in human consciousness is enfields so
there are there are links between these
as well and maybe the informational
patterns are being encoded in resonance
or quantum entanglement or even feel so
there can be links between these as well
the resonance theory that says The
Binding happens when things are in the
same frequency simple enough or when
they are close enough and that's becomes
a little bit more debatable but there is
you know what does that really mean
the boundaries there is
a conceptual solution for this which is
the slowest shared resonance in a system
but many of the same issues applies with
as with the algorithmic
um but again if experimented it it may
be possible to create create one that
works there
uh quantum theories entanglement is what
binds it together at least in some of
them so what you know what causes two
experiences a blue cut and the shape of
the cup to be bound together into one
well it's that the blueness and the
cutness I'm obviously talking at a very
high level of abstraction but those are
somehow Quantum entangled with each
other that would indeed create
to the best of our physics knowledge
today a kind of ontologically real
binding and that's that's quite an
attractive part of the solution
well what would stop those boundaries
there is the monogamy principle things
can only be maximally entangled up to a
certain point
but there's a very very open question
about whether that sort of thing would
would enable the kind of macro
phenomenology we have but in the paper
we say all of these are worth exploring
like let's let's keep investigating
and then there's the one I I started
with an instruction like maybe it's the
boundary of the central nervous system
but hopefully even a small amount of
scrutiny causes that one to uh to
collapse
and most of these explicitly say that
more work is needed more maths is needed
and certainly that will be true of what
we're presenting here as well
what we want to do is add a new one to
this list
and
the
the inspiration for this is that well if
the EM field accounts presents a
solution to The Binding problem they
certainly believe they do there's lots
of literature on it
then maybe they can also provide a
solution to the boundary problem given
how closely related they are
when you read those accounts
they don't quite have it nailed yet the
most common explanation they give is a
kind of inverse Square law rule where
well the strength of the field just
becomes so small so quickly you know by
the time you're a centimeter out from
the thalamus or by the time you're at
the edges of the skull these fields have
just evaporated into they did cohered
they're indistinguishable from the
neural noise all around us
that might be okay if you're okay with a
fuzzy boundary and we'll come on to that
in a sec I always motivate a phase
transition a bit like quantum
entanglement or a bit like the exact
Resonance of resonance theories
but those phase transitions are pretty
speculative as well
so
the solution where we will come to an
unusual outline is a different aspect of
VM Fields it's not fuzzy boundaries and
it's not a vague phase transition it's
an entirely different topological
solution which we argue can solve the
problems
what we think is worth doing though is
to make that boundary problem more
explicit
what you've heard both from Schrodinger
and from Rosenberg is this idea of and
like why aren't the cells inside you
conscious or if they are conscious why
don't we ever experience that and what
again going up what about cities and
families and things all group charts or
football stadiums that sort of stuff
oh and there is a there is a scholar who
argues based on resonance theory that
actually when we are in a group chanting
or a group dancing situation our
Consciousness does in fact move to that
level as well and that's it's
speculative but you know there are
there's much to be thought about
so to make this problem more precise
we've got five and I'll just give you
the the one or two sentences on each
the hard boundary problem
is
this sense that a fuzzy boundary
probably isn't good enough and that's
it's kind of explain a bit more why if
you have something like a wave or the
example of the wheel I gave before
touching the ground or indeed any
connection between any physical atoms
the closer you look to it the less
obvious it is where it stops
the boundaries of my skull may feel very
precise to me but if there were an alien
the size of a solar system their ability
to perceive this would most likely just
blurs imperceptibly into its
surroundings like these things feel hard
but they're not really hard
um
at the edges of our awareness there's
this sense that things like might feel
fuzzy but at some point
it just sort of stops might feel like it
might feel Infamous there are states of
mind where we can we can feel an
infinite awareness but probably bring
that further it doesn't truly Encompass
everything and go on forever
at this Edge our assertion is that
sometimes this feels like a hard
boundary
and if it ever sometimes feels like a
hard boundary then you need some
mechanism that is capable of a hard Edge
in a way that these physical phenomena
typically ask
so that's the heart boundary definitely
happy to like drill into more of any of
this or any of the other five if they're
not making enough sense
in the Q a so lower levels we covered
that that's
I mean the the great example of this is
um we know that when we go to sleep some
part of our Consciousness at least a bit
that we remember switches off yet the
brain remains active the lower levels
boundary problem could be reinterpreted
as saying why isn't why doesn't our
awareness just shift to another part of
the brain at that point it certainly
doesn't seem to most of the time
higher level boundary problem
we've had that from the beginning that's
why doesn't it go up maybe it does
sometimes certainly doesn't normally
the private boundary problem so this is
now rather than going down into
ourselves or up into the universe in
which we are nested this is more take
two of those boundaries
me and you me and one other person
why can we not Bridge into each other's
minds at least not routinely those who
claim to do so have struggled to
replicate it and get it into the
mainstream
so this is privacy there appears to be
some limitation that stops
these mechanisms from connecting with
each other and yet if it is slower
shared resonance or if it is highest
informational Phi in IIT why is it not
possible to construct a system in which
the highest fires now interconnected one
and our Consciousness is collapsed maybe
it is possible and that's just a
technical Endeavor we haven't yet
achieved by the way there's something
that's challenging about it either as a
technical barrier or as a philosophical
one
the last one is the temporal boundary
problem because everything we've said so
far
is in space
but the kind of entities and experiences
we're talking about are not zero zero
time space-based activities they have
they have a temporal persistence so what
is it that puts boundaries around a
micro moment of experience what is it
that enables us to experience the end of
a note and still retain that idea of the
start of the notes and experience them
together
and how does this extend through through
border experiences of the self so those
are the five puzzles
hopefully that's enough of a qualitative
overview so that you know what we're
trying to solve at least
and if I hand back over to Andrews now
he will give you an entirely new
solution to these puzzles
yes
uh next slide they're going a little bit
uh yeah kind of like a little bit
broader too in that uh what the Queen's
first talked about is kind of the
criteria for the boundary problem kind
of like breaking down the boundary
problem into subcomponents and then
there's like also like more broadly like
things that you would want out of a
theory of Consciousness and so like the
solution to the boundary problem ideally
will also in a sense like satisfy these
constraints uh and these constraints are
framing variants not only phenomenalism
and no strong emergencies next slide
so framing variants essentially can be a
recap Lawrence invariance uh the fact
that like
whatever structure is giving rise to the
boundary shouldn't in a way be frame
specific shouldn't just depend on like
how you're looking at an object it
should be kind of like an intrinsic
objective property of the object that if
you move it around it it should in
principle you know be changing in that
way next slide
for those who are not familiar with the
term this is the idea that for a
particular conscious physical system the
corresponds and experience but that
there's no causal influence from that
conscious experience back into the
system
and there's like various ways of kind of
uh trying to ground the question of hey
why why is epiphenomenalism not the case
um there's kind of again differences in
emphasis by each of these questions but
they're roughly pointing in the same
direction like one one important
question is how is it possible that we
can talk in detail about our experience
but the the way we actually framed it in
the paper that we find the most
compelling is
how was Evolution able to recruit you
know coherent globally bound
States if they're not causally
significant right like if they're not
causally useful it would just be an
extraordinary coincidence that it just
happens to to happen simultaneously
along with something that seems to be
computationally significant and you know
Encompass a whole lot of information at
the same time uh next slide
uh and then we also have no strong
emergence uh there's these yeah quote
from David that says the lagrangian or
the standard of the standard model does
not break down inside one's own skull
meaning we want the laws of physics to
apply universally to whatever
explanation space we come up with that
we don't want to introduce the special
cases or say like oh there's like a
special different field in the brain or
anything of the sort we want to have a
homogeneous
set of physics that
you know as simple as it gets as
mainstream As It Gets In terms of uh
appealing to the standard physics uh
next slide
uh so yeah the overarching solution and
explanation space that
the thing is electromagnetic field
topology so first of all I will walk you
through in what way these explanation
space satisfies the kind of like three
constraints that I provided and then
increase is going to explain how it
addresses each of the sub problems so
next slide
so yeah uh next one
yeah if you actually kind of look at
this uh amazing reconstructions of the
electromagnetic field of Stellar bodies
you would see that nothing trivial about
it right it's like all of this
incredible complexity and richness uh in
structure uh a lot of it is very
counterintuitive you know not something
that you would see with a naked eye you
see kind of this you require
um superimposing a lot of pictures from
the different regions of the spectrum to
kind of like get a picture of what's
going on in the electromagnetic field
and yeah it has kind of this
elongated weird plasma tubes and you
know circular structures and loops and
and so on uh this is a you know very
structurally rich environment uh next
slide
and you know the way in which you know
something like the topology of that
field will satisfy the criteria that
weight line is as follows so
if you look at the electromagnetic field
of the sun sometimes this phenomena
called magnetic reconnection happens and
this is actually responsible for solar
flares and kernel Mass ejections it has
to do with when plasma tubes that are
the
electromagnetic confinement structures
uh touch with each other and so they can
you know open up and spray plasma into
the the outer space
um the key thing to point uh about here
is that this is actually a topological
change to the field is it's not just any
kind of physical change you know when
you have a you know solar flare kernel
mass ejection that is the effect of a
top macroscopic gigantic topological
transformation what this slide is trying
to get at is that whether a system
experienced magnetic reconnection or not
will not depend on your frame of
reference and the very simple reason is
that lower ends transforms simply
squeeze and stretch but they never
actually you know reconnect or cut or um
you know add any kind of like
topological changes in other words a
Lawrence transform will leave a
topological event untouched so in that
sense okay like topology as an
explanation space for why
um why this is framing variant it
definitely fits the bill next slide
I importantly too yeah in the brain you
know this um we also can tackle the
question of like in what way the field
is not Epi phenomenal uh there's a lot
of research on local field Potentials in
the which are yeah little microscopic
electric oscillations
um and they do seem to actually have uh
causal effects on the activity of
neurons in other words uh
people might believe in a sense that hey
brain waves are kind of just a
reflection of neural activity but the
thing that something like transcranial
magnetic stimulation makes clear is that
on top of that they actually feed back
into the probability for neurons to fire
especially the probability for nearest
to fire in synchrony or in a in a state
of coherence in other words the actual
causal structure of electromagnetic
field and how it connects to neural
activity is this uh dual causal Arrow
where neural activity influences local
field potentials neural activity
influences activity via synapse
yeah we've been the victim of the
connection again let's hope it comes
back as quickly as as I did last time
hmm
yep
there's a lot to say but I won't
hopefully you've got some some hard
questions written down as we've been
we've been taking you through it
yeah just enough people who are
listening in the discussion
we'll uh look at some questions so
please feel free to write anything
personally I'm I'm curious whether the
awareness is gonna be the the light of
the Sun the heat of the Sun
the ejection
the loop structure the birth and death
of the star
yeah yeah I mean if that's
if the idea that you'll you'll see here
stands then you've got the idea that a
a closed topological pocket of
electromagnetic appeal that's that's
where awareness can take place that's
where a first person perspective that
kind of a lockers can exist but what
it's aware of well that's an entirely
different question and if there are
Pockets like that I mean we're not
asserting in this paper that the song
has these it's such a complex entity
it's very possible but that's you know
that is a different
but if to the extent they are there what
on Earth would be experienced within it
that's a
that's a different thing
the content
problem
it's not just for YouTubers
it's also for conscious systems
but yeah you've bound it all together
you've delimited a boundary
topologically
and then about what and so what
yeah yeah
it's me let me pick up a bit while we're
while we're waiting for him to comment
so
yeah this is and there's
really growing
kind of Neuroscience and biological
evidence for downward causation from
electromagnetic fields in the brain and
all we really do in this paper is
acknowledge that research literature
exists and say and therefore it's
possible for fields to be non-epi
phenomenal we don't get into the
specifics of it but they've been shown
in memory formation they've been shown
in the olfactory bulb your smells
they've appeared all over the place so
there's a ah Andres you're back yeah
just
making the case for non-effy phenomenal
feels fantastic really full yeah sorry
about that hopefully it doesn't happen
again okay next slide
yeah and uh
I mean think about like the immense
causal power that a topological change
in the field has in cosmological terms
you know like this
billions of tons of plasma being ejected
just because of you know otherwise like
maybe phenomenal magnetic reconnection
is like no no actually you know
topological Transformations are like
really really significant at a massive
massive scale uh next slide
yeah uh next one yeah just starting kind
of
how ridiculously powerful this can be
yeah and uh importantly too
um the actual fact
if you get an enclosure with a
topological transformation in a medium
also gives you this capacity to
essentially have holistic Behavior Uh
this is one of the things that to me was
kind of the most exciting about this
explanation space and like the moment
you can close field lines or you know do
a top formation waves will be confined
some kinds of waves can be confined
within a topological pocket when you
have confinement of waves then you have
resonant modes and when you have
resonant modes then you have these very
fantastic effect where the whole shape
of an object essentially is expressed in
the way every part of the object is
vibrating
in in which case yeah essentially you
have this reason why Evolution would
recruit you know these topological
objects is because it actually allows
organisms to behave as a unit so I think
yeah that might be a very key like piece
of the puzzle for for a phenomenalism
next to the slide uh these are just like
yeah kind of like some sketches of some
of the kinds of boundaries that in
principle you may have in the
electromagnetic field and what kind of
uh you know binding in Consciousness
they might correspond to
um but you know you don't have to you
know just speculate to the really
exciting thing here is that you can
actually play with simulations of the
electromagnetic field to try to make
sense of the topological Transformations
that happen in it uh so the next
following slides uh we can just go
through them fairly quickly
are essentially resonant modes of an
empty cavity electromagnetic resonance
modes of an empty Cube cavity where the
left side is the electric field and the
right side is the magnetic field
um
there are websites where you can check
this is uh called filestat.com embox
and the thing that it kind of like
really neatly shows is how the magnetic
field sometimes get this uh close
looping structure uh next slide yeah
just go through through them maybe like
five seconds for each of them
um and uh it also allows you to
essentially look at what happens when
you stack some of these resonant modes
and some combinations linear
combinations of these resonant modes
create intricate adding adding
uh headings and looks and twists that
loop around and create this topological
boundary very fleeting it has to do with
like the you know the frequency of
oscillation of the electric field you
know how many times per second you're
going to get this looping structure but
the fact that yeah you can show there's
some topologically closed objects uh
that appear there is quite remarkable
and overall the idea here would be that
well something like this is happening in
the brain and the brain is actually
recruiting this looping architectures
all right I'll hand it over to Chris
oh thank you very much yeah so we've
seen that electromagnetic fields can
form closed loops and people have used
that some of the sites in the paper
around people trapping knots of light
and it just kind of really remarkable
things happening at the edge of
um
sort of room temperature State physics
really incredible stuff
we know that in principle these fields
are capable of downward causation
um in massive context like the Sun but
also in very real human brain settings
so conceptually and we know that
topologies in general are frame and
variants so we've got we've got those
things in place we've got boundaries
that satisfy those those various
features that we wanted we don't know
exactly how they occur in the human
brain all we're presenting is a
conceptual solution that those things
are possible
but what we do say is well what would
what would such a solution look like to
those five uh boundary uh problems that
we just described
so taking them one by one
um or rather yeah taking them as a as a
group let's first say what
in such a theory
the first person perspective that kind
of phenomenal awareness the what it's
likeness that we experience in a very
normal
um everyday sense what could that
reflect what could that correspond to in
such a model and there are others but
we'll give one example and use that to
walk through the problems
so we would say that
once you've got a closed topology and it
may well require the time dimension for
it to be properly ontologically closed
and at that point
em energy of that specific Spectrum same
Spectra that's making up the boundary
can't pass through it well that's that's
the whole point about the closed loop
other things might pass through it the
sound wave might pass through it but
nonetheless for the entities that we're
interested in it is closed to itself and
that's where we get that's where we can
get this hard boundary
there may be lots of these being created
in the brain the brain is absolutely
chock-a-block with different bits of em
generating
um
underlying phenomena
so it's certainly plausible that some of
them are closed we don't know for this
to be true there must be at least one
but it's plausible that if there's one
there's probably several so you've got
several of these
by definition they are non-overlapping
they the boundaries cannot overlap but
they could well be multiple at the same
time one at the front run at the back
could be all over the place
it's probable though that only a subset
would be continually recreated in a
stable manner because the fact that
these brain these fields can have
downward causation they can do useful
things some of the sites in the paper
about information processing point to
some of the non-linearities you can
achieve through wave and field-based
resonant mode based
computations which may well have
benefits from from an information
process in perspective so in some cases
these will be continually recreated
only one of them because they cannot
overlap only one of them
can enclose let's call it an immediate
memory model as a conceptual Point not
not committing to what exactly that
might mean uh
we suspect these wouldn't last very long
and they probably don't extend over the
whole grain but who knows regardless it
would vary from period to period other
field theories might have other ways of
recruiting this concept for solving the
boundary problem but let's walk this one
through and see what it looks like as a
response to those five things so what
we're saying is
this closed topological pocket that is
kind of axiomatically the same as a
first person awareness when you've got
that you've got something that is a is
capable of both Binding Together those
micro bits of experience and presenting
them within a boundary so they have some
unified ontology
so
one by one and I think this is our last
slide
the hard boundary well that comes from
what we've been talking about energy of
the same Spectra can't pass through that
the closed loop so that that happens
quite naturally a bit like with the
field solution to binding this is
something you almost get for free as a
result of using that
low levels and higher levels
well it because only one of them because
of the non-overlapping point because
only one of them can include the
immediate memory model which is crucial
for the next bits
um
then you can't have lower levels and
higher levels there may well be mined
dust at those levels which is this kind
of lovely evocative concept maybe there
may well be
flashes of tiny bits of awareness that's
kind of
they never repeat the patterns just gone
through there's nothing that links it
into future versions of itself
um just gone the universe may be replete
with these things it's certainly got
plenty of electrons in it why not plenty
of these things who knows
um
but there's only one closed pocket
that maybe I'll come back to four that
can enclose this immediate memory module
and that's crucial because it's what
creates a temporal boundary that in any
possible sense could reflect what we
experience day-to-day because these tiny
if you if you think of the
these 4D Pockets if if one pocket were
to last long enough to Encompass say a
whole day's worth of your experience
it's almost impossible but it's a very
enough without breaking
to actually contain all the types of
complex phenomena we experienced during
the day which is why we think it's much
more likely they persist for a short
period of time but nonetheless our
experiences or things persisting for
longer
now the micro level persistence why is
it non-zero because if something is
infinitesimally small
it probably doesn't help us if something
is the equivalent of a geometric point
no matter how many of them you put
together in a physical setting you're
not going to create a line we want some
non-zero duration well we've got that
for free because the closed Pockets has
this for the ontological presence that's
fine
how would you get but it's but it may be
really really short far shorter than we
experience even this sentence
so what ties that together well because
it encloses
each millisecond to millisecond it
recreates
each one is a different piece of
awareness they are not in any way
ontologically linked to each other they
are each separate but because each one
encloses the memory module which is just
an information processing thing you can
encode memory and pen and paper there's
nothing magical about this by
referencing it it knows what was just
there before and that can create you can
it may we could call it an illusion if
you want whether that matters is a much
more philosophical point but you create
this pseudo-time Arrow you have unified
insights because that's what Fields do
they unify the insights in all the
things that make it up
no information is lost it is all bound
together
so now you've got the recent pasts and
then you've got the bit before that from
the previous pocket and a bit before
that and a bit before that so it's all
bound into each each individual presence
as short as it may be it has the sense
that it's something bigger
now in terms of the macro level days
years between interruptions
this is one where
where we're far more philosophically
relaxed it it may well be that there is
there is no kind of profound sense in
which these things are the same entity
it's maybe a ship of Theseus type type
concept and it's all linked together by
some fairly weak long-term memory and
are we really the same person as we were
a week ago a year ago we're far less
philosophically concerned about that
than we are by the micro level in the
meter level but either way the solutions
are the classic personal identity
Solutions which have been gone over
plenty of times
if if you'll give us another five
minutes before questions we'd love to
share some more kind of speculative
Thoughts with you
um that's yeah getting a thumbs up
wonderful in which case over to Andreas
for some for some fun thought poking
stuff well yeah awesome awesome yeah I
mean it's just kind of like this uh yeah
deeper question and uh don't wait for me
if my internet yeah runs out for a
second but uh yeah I mean essentially
how how does this influence for example
yeah relief of personal identity uh next
slide I think uh once you start seeing
the universe as a field and with maybe
like fleeting topological pockets on it
that actually varies significantly
informs these classic questions in
philosophy like who are you and do you
continue to exist from one moment to the
other and India the ship of the seers
like is there any kind of like
metaphysical enduring ego so to speak
and I actually think that each of these
um views of personal identity could
actually be
reinterpreted in terms of claims about
the field and field topology so
something like closed individualism this
is the belief that you start existing
when you're born stop existing when you
die or you know maybe you go to heaven
but the point is that you're
kind of a separate self that endures
over time that is different than other
selves
here we would want to find some kind of
uh enduring sheath or enduring nested
architecture that even though maybe each
moment of awareness might be its own
topological pocket maybe there's some
kind of higher order topological Unity
that does carry over a person's lifetime
you know that would be a possible way of
refining in a actual you know
significant physical way the sense of
identity over time of course completely
speculative would be a matter of
actually finding it in the fields but
that's how you could I think still men
this notion uh next slide
then uh probably the most compatible and
easy to justify view here would be empty
individualism that every moment of
experience is ontologically different
and again here that would be possible
because we would have these leading hard
boundaries in the space-time Continuum
and as a consequence you can yeah look
at the Block universe and say okay
there's a 40 pocket there there's a 40
pocket over there and wherever you see a
40 pocket that is going to be a subject
of experience and you know any actual
continuity between uh moments of
experience are
either just causal or kind of illusory
constructed with the memory module as
Chris was suggesting and then next slide
and then finally open individualism
there's this view that we are all one
Consciousness we're all Krishna at the
bottom bottom layers so to speak well
the way we could justify this within the
topological account is that well
actually
and at the deepest anthological level
we're all the field which has happened
to be on a given point in time a
segmentation of that field that prevents
the information propagation with other
regions of the field so in this case
kind of the the topological segmentation
would actually be more of a
epistemological boundary then it would
actually be an ontological boundary it's
like the idea that like deep down
actually we are the field it's just that
how the field knows itself is
constrained by its topology in in which
case yeah it's another way of Steel
Manning we're all one Consciousness in a
very physically grounded way and yeah I
think I think that's it unless I put
anything else in the next slide oh yeah
yeah just the last kind of like
speculation here is uh well okay if you
are this topological pocket in the field
uh electromagnetic field
um how can you in a sense take a look at
that pocket and then reconstruct what
the experience feels like and here
perhaps it's like a fun thought
experiment that you could you could make
is thinking about what it would be like
to be an affordant trapped in a within a
Hall of Mirrors uh there's this article
uh I wrote yeah 2018 about how to
replicate a hyperbolic space using just
double mirrors and uh gradient index
Optics uh and essentially within that
structure that has those properties a
photon would have no way of telling the
fact that it is not in hyperbolic space
in other words
the index of refraction of a container
would present itself as the actual
geometry of the space from within so in
our brain presumably like the actual the
actual way in which the local field
potentials are stitched together and the
relative index of refraction
could potentially give rise to really
arbitrary possible internal geometrics
where there's the illusion that you're
in a space whether it's in hyperbolic
space in spherical space on your regular
geometry all of those could be emulated
with these with these Paradigm and that
may go a little bit uh a long way in
actually explaining some of the most
exotic experiences that people can have
uh which usually would yeah challenge
kind of theories of Consciousness here
hear the story of us teaching them
together to to explain them and I think
yeah the last slide I believe
yeah
so this is yeah just illustrating that
point I think I think this is it yeah
yeah and we can leave this up on the
screen this is just where we would go
next with it but this seems like a good
point to stop and
hear your thoughts
awesome great presentations
well Bernie would you like to give a
first reflection and I'll write down
some questions and look in the live chat
yeah sure
um I've been thinking about about silver
stuff like this recently and um
um when it's I the paper presents how
the functional theories have the problem
of arbitraredness uh so for example with
Market blanket that can Market blankets
that could be the case uh when there's
micro blankets ontological observers and
I was thinking that maybe you need to
find this with the micro blanket
Paradigm is that
that on the physical level is
implemented as as using this topological
bucket is is the conscious marker
blicking so it's how you were referring
the marking black and solves the content
problem while the the topological
boundary solves all the other problems
like objects
which is
maybe at least
yeah no that's something very quick to
mention I mean obviously we're in the
active inference Institute uh podcast I
mean well absolutely one one thing to
mention is that
our perspective is not in itself
necessary or is not necessarily
sufficient actually to satisfy the you
know that we have specified
um however we actually think it's very
very likely that topological pockets in
the electromagnetic field do behave as
marked with blankets and so it is in
which you can actually interface these
different paradigms where we would be
saying that at the implementation level
you know and then realize the
immunization of free energy at the
algorithmic level however we would be
saying and maybe this would be a little
bit of a Twist or a non-trivial
implication that if you were to simulate
a you know hierarchically structured
Market blanket system in a computer it
could very well be from a certain
abstraction be minimizing free energy
but it wouldn't have this it wouldn't be
able to solve the boundary problem in
other words it is sort of like there is
a significant overlap but uh there are
some slight places are very Divergence
where you might say hey Marco blanket is
actually not enough because it doesn't
give you the implementation level
explanation for how you get boundaries
all right Chris if you want to add
anything yeah yeah I mean just to just
to agree with that I think this is the
the if you go back to Mars three levels
around kind of what
substrate and
we haven't discussed anything here about
the algorithms that are actually taking
place on
or kind of within the brain that would
ultimately get incorporated into the EMP
Fields clearly you need that stuff as
well none of this goes makes any
contribution to solving these more
content problems with Consciousness or
how we make inferences about the world
how we respond to those
what it does say is that for
if there are algorithms that solve those
problems and there are some good
candidates out there including yours
they need to be
implemented or they need to reflect back
to a field for it to become part of
someone's Unified
macro phenomenological experience if you
did a some sort of feed forward in
silico version of this or you did it you
implemented the algorithm using rocks
just lots and lots of rocks laid out
forever like that wonderful XKCD example
that
that is not going to create a bound
first person perspective anywhere
well a lot to say about that certainly
Mark all blankets and just to Define it
on a Bayesian graph so the map not the
territory the Markov blanket is the set
of nodes upon which two other sets of
nodes are conditionally independent and
that's a purely topological statement it
doesn't matter how far if there even is
a spatial Association or temporal
Association it doesn't matter the
distance which is to say the geometry
but rather the blanket is a purely
topological statement and that's what
among other things we've been exploring
with Chris fields in the physics is
information processing and this question
about the topology of communication for
bounded Observers
and as we kind of alluded to with that
content problem
the topology of communication is to use
a geometric metaphor it's orthogonal to
the the content you could have two
people on the phone sharing different
things you could have a video file with
different contents and so there there's
really a lot of layers that come into
play and so I think from an
instrumentalist View
I read your paper as a call for the
introduction of topology into what is
often only modeled as geometric
a call for the integration of
electromagnetism rather than a Reliance
on one of the other of course as
introduced from the outset of pluralism
these are not exhaustive nor exclusive
accounts and we don't know what the
scope of the possible intelligences and
awarenesses are so from a research
perspective if not Beyond why would we
want to limit when we're not only
interested in understanding the
properties of Any Given system as we see
it today
any thoughts or I can read a question in
the chat
yeah that sounds great
TurnKey tyranny writes how does topology
show up phenomenologically
yeah this is a excellent excellent
question uh I'm happy to thank you to go
back to your notes you know we've got
that page of notes in there so Elizabeth
because this this is because I I've
asked a very similar question of Andreas
and that these sort of notes is what
resulted in in his attempts to explain
it to me so let me tell you yes very I
mean this is very speculative and uh but
but
one one wonderful resource I think I
think hopefully I think is wonderful a
very worth uh trying out is we made a
um series of guided meditations about uh
phenomenology they're not it's not
really kind of like about secret
spirituality it's more for the sake of
exploring phenomenology uh with
meditation the last one is called the
phenomenology of ontology and that one
helps you in a sense get a sense of
I believe subordinary reality
acts direct reality of course
different to believe that new
electromagnetic field or you're an
electromagnetic but it feels like
crystals or in a specific version of
materialism or something like that so
very different ontologies can give rise
to very different feelings
um and so there's definitely the worry
that like well if you think a lot about
the electromagnetic field aren't you
maybe just interpreting your Sensations
within that Paradigm but like it's kind
of like you're overfeeding on top of it
um but uh you know in a sense I would
argue that actually it's the other way
around with something as generative and
structured as electromagnetic field you
can think in principle explain the
phenomenology of any ontology like why
does it feel like for example that you
um uh you can kind of like merge with
the cosmos or something like that why
does it feel like you can become one
with everything in meditation let's say
in various meditation States well with
something like the topological
explanation for uh the boundary problem
the way we might interpret that is as
the vanishing of internal boundaries and
so there is a significant difference
between a global boundary which is what
we focused on the overall kind of the
macroscopic division that says whether
you're inside or outside your experience
but something that the electromagnetic
field also affords and gives us as kind
of part of its Rich structure is the
possibility of internal boundaries as
well which would be not boundaries that
encomp
um that um wrap around a 4D object but
rather lower dimensional boundaries like
meeting points or convergence points of
the field lines within the pocket and so
in this account you know whenever you
have like the sensation of solidity the
feeling of well I am here you're there
or there's a boundary between us
that boundary would essentially be an
internal boundary would be a region of
the field well the field lines converge
or they they align
um but it's only along a certain
cross-section meaning that you know
actually your experience is still fully
unified you can still go from one point
to the other across a perceived barrier
because they're still part of the the
whole experience they're still connected
in other words with this kind of data
structure
we can arrive at kind of like a lot of
um phenomenological details and trying
to explain them from from that
perspective uh and I think it's going to
be a enormous program in in the long
term you know involving physicists and
mathematicians and exotic States Of
Consciousness to say like okay that
particular feature of experience that
happens on certain substance in such a
such meditation state
how does that uh map into the
electromagnetic field and I think we
will very likely find a lot of
non-trivial connections with that that
sort of paradigm
press any thoughts on that
uh just to make the link to this uh to
some of the the diagrams on the page
which is
if you've got these
non-4d closed boundaries but other types
of boundaries the other types of shapes
Andrews was talking about the drawings
on the page are just examples of some of
those
but and and this is as Andrew said it's
not really part of the solution but it's
part of Imagine to be exploring where
else it might go so if you've got you've
got feature binding which is you know
I'm seeing a cup in the cup is both blue
and cup shaped
that's feature binding and then the
phenomenological binding is my whole
experience being being unified you can
imagine feature binding putting the
blueness and the couplers together that
might be something that happens along
one of these types of internal
boundaries it might not it might be that
that can be done purely through
informational associations where we're
kind of agnostic on that but what's
interesting about a 4D topology is
within it you can have lots of other
complicated topologies provided they are
not closed along the fourth dimension
because then you've got you sort of
created another little mini awareness oh
Bernie go ahead yeah I'll jump back to
the other page uh yeah I wanted to say
something else uh not related to this
exact question so if you have ended it
maybe I'll yeah okay well in that case
actually I'll mention one last thing
about the how electromagnetic field may
be related to phenomenology uh a very
specific thing that happens on
psychedelics and especially something
like DMT is that you may end up having
uh different regions of your experience
have the exact same texture and have the
feeling of synchronization between them
and when that happens they sort of
become the same object just like
spatially distributed
um the way I interpret this is whenever
the exact same wave equation applies to
two regions of your experience and waves
can propagate from one region to the
other that actually feels like they're
the same object so one kind of like
natural way in which yeah regions of
your phenomenal world might be segmented
out into phenomenal objects is by
confining how waves can move within the
world simulation and whenever you have a
what feels like a bound object in your
world simulation that I think is highly
highly related to waves being able to
smoothly travel within that object but
not outside of that object some kind of
wave confinement is happening
I'll add in one more of course fun and
speculative thought which is the
aboutness the content of what this
computation or what this process is
unfolding the aboutness itself can be
structure learning and so even for a
fixed electromagnetic topology you can
have variable informational topology
case in point the Von Neumann computer
the CPU architecture electromagnetically
is not changing topologically we don't
need to reroute the telephone
connections for there to be different
messages that spread and so there's a
lot of richness in in the space you've
you've sketched or surveyed because even
for a fixed topology we might be able to
do compositional
um binding like blue and cup
and then now we add in
a dynamic multi-scale
topological
unfolding
and then that may connect to different
frequencies of for example measurements
in the EEG which are really only picking
up the synchrony in the outer shell
which might actually play a role it's
not like the skull matters you could
have a skull removed it's not the scalp
it's not your hair
it's not necessarily the meningi but
what is it well maybe it's something
that's info topological that reflects
kind of different regimes of attention
that that actually does happen to
correspond but it's also localized and
that's that interplay with individuality
and and Oneness that works like Wilbur's
no boundary Point towards but then you
got to come back from no boundary
because that sentence has to end
yeah
Bernie
yeah I wanted to mention that in
relation to the ongoing course on the
physics and information processing that
Chris Fields is is hosting is one one
construct that Chris Phillips is using
in in his papers with Michael and inspo
is the is the notion of topological
Quantum neural networks and topological
Quantum field theories so it might be
that those are the the the the the
information processing in in this kind
of topological Maps as well that you've
mentioned Daniela the uh
grounding for that or how Michael Levin
is talking about how Bill electricity is
a glue uh
for for
the various subsystems in the brain or
uh based on placing some recent paper
that was pretty late that that use
there's this whole I I know I I found
out recently which which I put the uh
surprised up just recently that there is
a whole whole field of people uh that
are really trying uh to apply Quantum
field theory on the brain and there was
one paper on memory formation so how you
Chris talked about uh memory in terms of
the electromagnetic field that might be
also great like for pointer so I'm just
putting out uh different people and
papers that I think might be
interconnectable with this word
yeah one one interesting thing you
reflected it in your literature review
is when people think about Quantum and
cognitive systems the orc or and other
Frameworks often are considering Quantum
as being electronic scale and therefore
a quantum theory of cognition or
Consciousness would entail some kind of
relationship between the way that
electrons and photons behave and then
some difference that makes a difference
at the biological level and in a way
what we've been exploring with Chris
fields and others is like a bypass where
it's like no the quantum formalism
Quantum topology Quantum information
simply and plainly describes cognitive
processes where like order matters now
there may or may not be effects
associated with differences that make a
difference at the electronic scale but
we don't need that in order to use like
superposition and all of these diff
different effects that empirically are
the case in cognitive systems we're not
waiting for some new mechanistic insight
it'd be cool to find out but what you've
presented is uh not waiting for a
different kind of thing to exist
so I'm curious what experiments or what
are the unique experiments
that you feel like would give
a resounding feeling
on what you're talking about
yeah happy that they could uh take it on
so uh
uh one kind of like very awesome
research lead and then I'll explain what
a research Paradigm would look like but
essentially a first of all like a very
powerful lead is meditative cessations
so one of the most insane chapters in
mastering the core teachings of the
Buddha by Daniel Ingram is the one
called the three doors where he
describes the phenomenology of
experiencing a peak meditation State
that's called a cessation where you
blink out of reality for a second or
well for a sub second moment but you
just blink out fully and then you get
reconstituted and when you get
reconcited it tends to be a very
Blissful very rejuvenating type
experience
but the things he highlights in that
article is what it feels like to be
really close to a cessation
and it actually depends on what type of
cessation it is there's roughly like
three ways in which it can happen but
the mind-blowing thing about that essay
that chapter
is he essentially describes different
topologies of attention and awareness
that may arise where in these moments
close to Association if he says well in
one of those you become kind of a Taurus
and the Taurus flips the inside and then
outside and it twists around and then it
cancels out and compresses and then you
vanish and then there's like another
variety where you become a cone and then
you all of your attention gets
concentrated in the point of the
chlorine of the cone and then that
twists around and then vanishes and
so there's like this reliable you know
very very uh exotic kind of like
topological Transformations that can
happen to your attention and awareness
and our guess would be that well a
sensation you know an actual kind of
full Vanishing might be related to the
topological pocket that your brain is
generating essentially opening up so
that in some maybe non-trivial way the
actual boundary between inside and
outside gets dissolved or a fraction of
a second then it gets reconstituted but
something really special happens in that
that moment that allows for deep Insight
or something along the lines or
relieving a lot of internal stress maybe
like a coronal mass ejection there might
be something something going on going on
at the topological level
um now in terms of yeah kind of like
further you know more sophisticated
research paradigms the thing that we're
looking into
um there's a lot more to be unpacked and
developed here but is what kind of
electromagnetic resonance modes that can
supervene on particular graphs you know
whether we're talking about their
connectum or whether we're talking about
you know the the geometric eigen modes
more more recent work where you model
the entire cortex essentiometric uh
geometric surface and then you apply
neural field Theory to that well so like
what kind like all of that works so far
essentially what it focuses on is
oscillations in the electric field
without modeling the magnetic field so
I'm actually you know I would suspect
that many of the connective harmonics or
eigen mode uh geometric eigen modes may
be physically unrealizable simply
because the magnetic field lines May
collide with each other so like some of
those may not be possible but one of the
crazy fascinating unusual predictions
that may come out of our whole Paradigm
is that once we have a really good
mapping of what resonant modes
um arise in the brain on different
states of Consciousness we would take
that a when you're fully awake normally
conscious there will be a very Central
big topological Loop inside you that
whenever you're let's say in deep Sleep
you might see a kind of mind dust you
might see lots of tiny little little
pockets and maybe when you're in an
ecstatic you know experience like like
deep meditation
it may do something else like the
particular resonant modes there may
create open field lines that don't form
a loop so that is like the sort of crazy
very novel type of prediction or at
least research Paradigm that this
enables
that's that's really cool Chris anything
out of that
yeah I've just uh draw the link between
the fourth bullet here and what Andrews
is setting out
I don't think any of this is there are
some toy bits of modeling you could do
that could increase confidence one way
or another but in terms of an actual
experimental prediction
you would need to combine this with some
theory of where which bits of the brain
are doing this so if Ward and Guevara
are right that it's the thalamus that's
doing this stuff
we would expect to see around the
thalamus a closed pocket and it should
be possible in principle like this is
probably billions of pounds worth of
efforts but to model the thalamus and
the surrounding bits enough and you can
find out if there would actually be a
closed pocket if there would be one in
theory you can see roughly where it
would be it moves around a bit but it's
normally around here you then should be
able to I don't know if ethical consent
is even possible for something like this
but disrupt that with a very very
targeted external em source
think you know transcranial stimulation
but just you know laser precise
if we've now broken the bit around the
thalamus but left everything else more
or less untouched we predict if Warden
Guevara plus us is correct we predict
that your first person awareness would
blink out like deep sleep like
anesthesia like a meditative cessation
if we're wrong or the combination of us
is wrong then you'll still be conscious
but you might just experience something
really bloody weird but you'll still
expect your contents have changed not
the not the actual container of
Consciousness hasn't blinked in and out
and then you could apply that to other
bits of the brain wherever you think
there's I mean our other
other prediction is that it must be
enclosing the immediate memory model
that we're unsure exactly where that is
as well that that is also an outstanding
research question so this is I mean it
feels like doable in our lifetimes I
think but none of this is you know give
us 10 grand and we'll do it this summer
none of it is that easy
um yeah very interesting and
neuroimaging
already utilizes electromagnetic
measurements and there are things that
currently are described within a
biomolecular paradigm like for example
changes in effective connectivity
between different regions of the brain
well there's already a tract let's just
say between certain brain regions and so
maybe if there's
um if the action potential is traveling
down that 100 Lane Highway
or lines then it's going to be like this
Rippling em continuity whereas if they
were totally disarrayed along that tract
then you you wouldn't have those two
regions contained but it'd be like kind
of like two regions like blowing smoke
rings at each other if they had enough
synchrony to to push through the trouble
and the friction
such that there was a pocket that was
able to you know you you squirt hot
water into a cold pool
there's ways to angle it and do it in
all of the combinations of viscosity
that it just diffuses instantly
there's also ways where there would be a
high temperature
toroidal form that could pass through a
colder media
because it maintains a topological
boundary
a lot of these things are again
described anatomically or molecularly or
electronically
but the magnetic The Duality between
electronics and magnetism is not
contentious
so there may be a lot of phenomena
that
could be Revisited
and I don't know whether that would
provide indirect evidence with what we
already know
um or suggest new plausible experiments
but
it's an approach
yeah welcome it and thanks Bernie as
well for the points us towards like
Chris fields and Michael Levin I may
come back to you for the uh the qft and
on memory formation in case I've spotted
some stuff on that but I'm not sure I've
spotted the one it sounded like you were
referring to so yeah it's an exciting
time this sort of research yeah one last
connection there with with active
inferences you have the electronic and
the magnetic fields influencing each
other that's the the basis of what
philosophers
might consider in terms of this Epi
phenomenalism or not question and
um if we had an active inference
situation of two songbirds the act of
states of one become the sensory of the
other
so if they were just passing messages
every single time step to each other
then they would both be engaged in their
own blanketed perception on the inbound
and action selection on the outbounds
and so they could basically be in this
continual oscillatory relationship with
causal efficacy both ways again or you
could design a situation where the
causal efficacy only flows one way
but the point is this is the topological
approach that lets us explore that in a
way that isn't only appealing to
molecular
or material phenomena and then leaving
the whole question which is the whole
question of the informational and the
closure and The Binding leaving all
those to be resolved by slicing and
dicing with a scalpel
which is not even
a viable option as far as we already
understand
Bernie and then the authors
what are your closing thoughts or
how would you suggest that people get in
the game or what should they do with
their own topologies
maybe I could note that Andres could
expand on if he wants to know uh
any link
well yeah I mean I guess the at the PRI
I mean has to be introduced by Mike in
2015 on principia qualia but the their
correspondence respondents between
um
uh yeah you know like
of the tri for many years now you know
you can see a 2020 presentation about it
in this many more content about it but
the the main idea the way it would
actually you know work out here is the
regions of the topologically closed uh
field that behave like a smooth field
May potentially correspond to a very
Blissful experience so you know I'm very
very optimistic of the potential of okay
like something like a peak uh Blissful
experience Big 5 mu DMT experience or
something like that it would probably I
suspect have like a very internally
simplified topology
where you know the geometry is as smooth
as possible so that's kind of like an
interesting yeah prediction or or angle
and on all of these uh I think yeah
maybe to to wrap up I would say that we
you know would enormously welcome
anybody who is uh technically Savvy for
like uh doing interesting simulations of
the electromagnetic field I mean we are
we're doing ourselves some like really
interesting experiments and in
combination with a classical neural
networks but anybody's kind of like a
you know the intersection between
machine learning uh electromagnetic
fields and simulations and
yeah you know statistics machine
learning essentially that that kind of
intersection is something that could
really potentially accelerate these
research you know if you had the
technical competency to yeah sort of
like work on the analysis I was
describing or finding the
electromagnetic resonant modes of our
graph and then analyzing its topology
you know we would love to collaborate
that's like the sort of content we
we dream of producing and yeah in the
next year or two so
thank you and thank you for having us
it's been fantastic really really
appreciate it
I appreciate that Chris
you need nothing substantial to that
just just just my thanks as well and you
know I've I've scribbled down some
thoughts about about the Marco blankets
and about some of those different
research areas as well so you know we're
getting stuff from this as well so yeah
and hopefully this helps reach a few new
people who might come up with either a
brilliant idea why something we'd Miss
and this this just can't work for
somebody we want to hear that as well
um but even more constructively ways
that this could be tested or built out
more gradually modeled
um
yeah thank you for having us cool new
ways of thinking within even one
topological frame enables new action
selection in the area and the era of
video chatting we've made new
topological relationships new
connectivities that then disperse yet
again
and so it continues
thank you all though
thank you so much until next time thank
you amazing stuff see ya bye